みなさんこんにちは
私は信州山形村でそば処も ok を経営させてもらっています
花は家族と申します
今日のテーマなんですけども自分の店を持つ方法です
福島県出身の私が昨年4月何の小屋もなかったこの信州で長年の夢だった
そばやを開業することができました
突然ですけどもこの中で夢を持っていらっしゃる方いらっしゃいますか
結構いらっしゃいますねありがとうございます是非お聞きしたい
私もですね昨年自分の夢を叶えさせてもらって学んだことがあります
それは
夢は一人で叶えるもんじゃないということです
私には大切にしている3つ論
考えがあります
一つ目が行動
二つ目が合って
そして3つ目が感謝です
私はずっとこの3つを大切にしてきました
逆にこの3つがあったからこそ今があるのだというふうに思っています
今日はですねこの行動で愛感謝
私の過去を少し振り返りながらみなさんに話を聞いていただき
何が少しでも何かきっかけになっていただけるなというふうに思っていますよろしくお
願いします
さあ
ではなぜ私がそば職人になろうと思ったのか
実はですね私高校生の時からアルバイトしたお金で蕎麦の食べ歩きをしていたんです
名前機にもねぇ側ノートみたいな付さん
何がにそば店
一番誰かの為ですよ天ざるそば1,800円
味の評価花丸20万円三角なんてつけて本当に生意気な高校生だったと思います
そしてもう一つ
小さい時からですね7 y 2
手に職をつけなさい転職をつけばどこへでも生きていけるという風に育てられてきまし
た
21歳の時仕事の転機が訪れました
自分の好きな事を仕事にしようと思ったんです
俺し大人に好きかなーって思ったんですけどあの側のと南たんですよ
あ俺そうは好きなんだじゃあ
そば職人になりたい思ったんです単純に
そば職人になるためには蕎麦屋の修業しなきゃいけません
側の卒業するためには修業先を探さなきゃいけないんです
どこで雇ってくれたからってすごい悩んだんですけどよくれ父はに連れてってもらった
福島市にあるそば処も ok という素材についてと思いました
美味しいですよ本当に
私はねまあ親方に連絡をとって直訴したんですよ
これがたすいません
俺側打ってみたんですけど
レシィしていくんですか勢いでした
そしたらね親方はよしじゃあ花はムスクならしょうがねえな
2年間期限付きでやっ頑張ってみろという風に言ってもらえたんです
これが私とお家型の出会いです
最初は慣れない仕事を
here is つ
ロスけどまぁアリかアドバイスじゃあにょある日兄も出せるんだったんん
忘れられない出来事があります
その日はですね常連さんのお客さんが見えてたまたま私のそばを食べて来たんです
帰り際にねお金を張ってたと思うん
今日の曽我あなたが打ったんだってね美味しかったよって言ってもらえたんですよ
私その時に嬉しくて中央で男泣きしました
その時に決めたんですよ
自分で作ったもので人を喜ばせることができる
だったら俺は側の道で生きてくって決めました
それからね仕事が毎日楽しくなってたんですよ
施行期間は2年間です2年間のうちの残り半年ぐらいなった時に親が誰に言われました
そろそろ二年経つけどお前次何か考えているのか
南京も考えてなきゃいけ
すっごい焦ったんですよ
どうしようかなぁ
すぎなんかまたら行動しなきゃいけないなと思いました
でとった行動がかこちら
信州そばを食べにいっ
いう風構造だったんですよ単純に
信州蕎麦って全国でも高いブランド名ですよね
でも一体何なのかなと思ったんですよ30人
じゃあ旅行ってみよう何かあるかもしれないと思って
そば好きの友達をさせましたちょっと側ため行くじゃん
で観光がいたのでまあ観光回答を買いまして
いろんなとこ行きましたよ
善光寺安曇野のわさび農場
あと
上田城とが諏訪コスは対し
ものすごく感動しましたよこんなところがあるんだなぁと思っ
ノープランの旅だったんですよね私
でたまたま降り立ったのが
夕焼けの松本城なんですよみてください綺麗でしょ
私ねこの前に買った時に鳥肌立ったんですよ
なんときれいなところなんだ
これもその時に直感で住みたい俺ここに住みたいって決めたんですよ
そして
じゃ
今日は素泊まりの宿をとって松本はいっぱいのもって決めました
1等店がですね
蕎麦屋じゃなくて一見が焼き鳥屋さんだったんですよ
焼き鳥の対象高橋さんって言います
誰かしたのですね美味しい焼き鳥を焼いてくれて親子の子だけ
一杯飲みました
私ねそりゃまあ呼ばれますよ美味しかったす
酔っぱらった勢いで高橋さんに言ったんですよ
高さ
俺も親子を超えちまって
4種住みですけどなんか仕事ですかねぇ
何でもやりますよと言ったんですよした方が資産が本命文字玲奈はカット買ったって
言って名刺交換しました
これが私と高橋さんの出会いです
福島に帰って私は信州のことが忘れられなくて
すっごい毎日モヤモヤした気持ちだったんですよね
何かできないかなーと思ってたんですけど
物事をシンプルにあの高橋さんにお礼がしたいと思ったんですよ
そして
俺上位機使いてお蕎麦を打って高さに送ってみました
そしたらすぐに連絡来まして
ははーん仲がいい育っちゃう
これもなあなあと前の粉キーになってな色々調べたんだけど
実はな添えを経営している社長いってのキーと族へ
なんと職人を1人募集してるっていう話なんです
私はでも鳥谷が立ちまくっちゃって今も経ってるんだけどね
そう今度は一人で信州に入って
焼き鳥の高橋さんとソバ屋の社長当該して信州への思い
側への思いをお伝えしたところなんと福祉の出身の私を雇ってくださったというわけな
んです
それが23歳の秋のことです
いざ誰もいない新種と同じ誰もいません
最初はがむしゃらに仕事してました
もう少しずつねあの1人が出てくると私ものすごい寂しがり屋なんでよく寝飲みに来た
んですよ
一人で
簡単にた方が座っていた高
私ナンパしないんであのきれいが男性
ね女性ではないですナンパしません男性とかにちょっと声かけて私福島だけなんだけど
友達になってるんですかーみたいな
先ほどもうちょっと映像ありましたけど古いビートル乗ってたんですよ
仕事帰りに古い人を見つけては車でをかけてバーンうーん
10分以上もう怖いですよね恐怖ですよ
10分以上をかけてようやくコンビニ止まってもらって
俺福島から来たんすけどって言って友達作っていったんですよ本当に
いまでもその彼とはワーゲンイベントを一緒に行ったりもしています
そんな活動したところ信州でね
親友と太町ができたんです
彼は私と増粘です
私と一緒で人の出会いやはを大切にしている
仲間でした
彼はねものすごい勢いで私を紹介しました
こいつ福島から来たかずつってさぁちょっと暑苦しくめんどくさいんだけどいいヤツな
んだよって言ってくれて
友達がねどんどんどんどん広がっていったんですそしたらね気づいたら私端まで消化し
てもらっちゃったんですよ
ねもう本当に彼には頭が上がりません
現在私4人の子供がいます
この信州が第二の小京都思えるくらえ
根付かせてもらったんです記録ありがとう
話は少しずつ本題に戻していきます
自分の店を持つ方
私もいつかは自分の店を持とうと思っていました
でも具体的に何も考えてませんでした
そんな所
人生を変えた出来事がありました
それがあの東日本大震災だったんです
私の呼吸福島は
つなぎの被害だけではなくて
原発の事故といまだに解決的な問題がたくさんあります
私は自分に何かできることはないかなって毎日考えてました
自分にできることそれはそば打ちだったんです
だったら育ちをして炊き出しいけないかという風に考えたんですね
行かせてもらったのが2011年の4月かな
なる写真がいわきはいわきの店は津波で流されて何もなかったです
あの光景は今でも忘れません
その議論に気持ちのままですね避難所に向かったんですけど
避難所は喪失感いただけましたそれもそうですよね
私はただ方がむしゃらにそばを打ちました
そして
あるおじいさんと出会ったんです
そのおじいさんはお話を聞きすると津波で家族を亡くされたおじいさんでした
それでも私は
ただそばを打つことしか出来なくてなんてちっぽけなんだなと思ったんですけど帰り
外装のおじいさんが
兄ちゃん側美味しかったよありがとうねって言ってあっちして来たんですが俺
この経験を得て私は
生かされた子の命120%生きなきゃいけないなって学ばせてもらいました
この経験ができたのも私が炊き出しきたいって言った時に背中を押してくれたたくさん
の協力さんがあったおかげだったんです
ありがとうございます
実際に cc に帰ってじゃあ具体的に夢を描いてみようという風に考えました
とった行動が夢音です
この夢ノートには何が書いてあるかというとお店の名前とか
席数はどのぐらい数メニューはこんな感じの端
頭のあることを全てノートに書いていきましたすると面白いことに何が問題でその問題
を解決するためには何をしなきゃいけないのかっていうのがどんどんどんどん具体化し
ていったんですよね
もう一つやってて良かったのが出張そば打ちです
人と人をつなぐ側会と言っていろんなとこ行きました
こちらですね
東京のホテルで当ててもらいました
福島の仲間と福島の酒蔵さんがですねみんな手伝ってくれまして
東京から福島を発信しようという側会を開かせてもらいました
こちらですね
新種の仲間と福島の仲間の駆け足を作ろうという風にして聞かされました
今現在この仲間たちがすごく
すごくすごく深い関係を築いてくれます
こいつ便面白いですよ神奈川県の自室にある蕎麦屋さんで側会
ね蕎麦屋よりいってそばを打つんですよ職人いっぱいいるのにん
この回のテーマはですね七夕でした七夕の日に
福島にですね思いを短冊に書いてもらって届けるっていうプロジェクトでした
2年間やらせてもらったんですけどいまだに家族のような関係を築かせてもらってます
私が出会った方にですね
お礼状か言ってたんですよね
感謝の気持ちっていろんな表現方法があると思うんです
またをねっていうの奥地のは簡単なんですけどもやっぱり
手書きで書くことって気持ち伝わるなそう
あの高橋さんに行ったことあったんですよねだからずっとずっと続けてました
そしてようやくおととしの9月
信州山形村に物件が見つかったと仲間からられなくなって行ってみたんですけども
その物件の前に立った時ですね私
直感で決めたんですよ
あ俺小ボタン
なんでかっていうとあの夢ノートに書いてあったことがイメージできたんですよ
俺はここでできるんだ
そう
そしてこの山形村でやろうというふうに決めました
いざ開業準備ありますと今まで出会ってくださった人たちが開業準備中なのに毎日の
ように差し入れを持ってきてくれたり
これ右の写真一緒に鍋とかやってねすっごい楽しかったんですよ
真ん中の写真私の父手に職と言って
ハウスクリーニングの仕事をしています
お金は出せないかといって何度も何度も通ってくださいました
こうちゃん本当にありがたかったです
そして2014年4月11日念願のそばやを開業することができました
なぜこの日を選んだかというと東日本大震災から丸3年たった1ヶ月
月命日です
あの日のことを
忘れないように
私はこの日を開業ミニしました
福島出身の私が何の合意もないこの信州で夢だった相撲を完了できたのは間違いなく
出会い
支えてくださったみなさんのおかげなんです
行動出会い感謝これは
すべて繋がっていると思います
新しく行動するときってすごく時々しますよね
例えば私今日ここのステージに立たせてもらってますけど
お誘いを受けたとき
仕上げて着るかなって思ったんですよでもその人がね
楽しいよって言ってたのでじゃあやるって決めたんですよ
実際に派実際に参加させてもらっていろんなことを学びました
自分を振り返ることもできましたし
何より皆さんと出会いました
一歩踏み出す勇気ってものすごくドキドキしますけどやっぱりやってよかったなと思い
ます
次は
アラタたちの番だと思います
皆さんは今日ゴールデンウィークの最中チケットを買ってこの場所に来るという行動さ
れました
きっと意識レベルの高い方たちばかりだと思うんですよね
ちょっと周り3番してくださいのちょっと
ねえキラキラした2 g こちらから見るとすごいいっぱいいるんですよね
これがきっと出会いだと思うんですよどうですか
これが出会いだと思うんですよね
私から一つお願いがあります今日
たった一人でもいいから友達作ってください
10人中10人と仲良くすることができません
でも10人中たったひとり心から繋がるとその人がまた10人を紹介してくれると思う
んです
自己紹介恥ずかしいですよ
僕学生なんですけど将来こんなことをやりたいんですとか
俺山形村で医師ややってるんだけど
これの夢ってこんなんだよねー
とか
分かる人は分かるんですけど
ぜひね熱い握手を交わしてぜひ自分の夢を語ってみてください
何か変わると思いますよ
私はそうやってやってきました
夢は1人で考えるものじゃありません
どれだけその夢に
共感してくれる仲間と出会いチームを作るかなと思っています
33さえまだまだ未熟者ですけどもこれからも一期一会を大切に
行動出会い
感謝を繰り返して最高のチームもう形を作っていきたいとおもいます
最後になりますけどもテレックス松本本当にたくさんのボランティアスタッフの皆さん
が関わってくださっています
このステージに立てるのもスタッフの皆さんのおかげですありがとうございました
そしてスピーカーのみなさんおつかれさまでした一緒に緊張しましたね
聞いてくださった皆さん皆さんがあってこのイベントが成り立っていると思います
またあなたとあなたとお会いできる日を楽しみにしていますご静聴ありがとうござい
ました